for over a decade the MCU has introduced
audiences to just about every kind of
villain tragic figure and Nair do well
you could possibly imagine some are a
complete Miss but some you'll never
forget here's every villain in the MCU
ranked from worst to first in the Dark
World curse leads a prison riot helps
malachith sack Asgard and kills Thor's
mother Friga he also leads a battle
against Thor in the film's climax
beating the Thunder God senseless with
his brute strength but even with all
that curse is still little more than a
forgettable monster with no personality
penrith hella's enormous wolf is an
undead Beast who tries to finish off the
Asgardian refugees toward the end of
Thor Ragnarok to the wolf's credit the
menacing green eyed monster definitely
looks cool but sadly veneres really
doesn't do much Ezra hella animates her
beloved familiar he just sort of hangs
out and looks mean while the death
goddess interrogates a crowd of scared
as Guardians in the final battle Fenris
tries and fails to kill the Hulk on the
one hand it's nice to see another bad
guy from Thor's Rogues Gallery fit into
the film on the other hand it seems like
the only reason Fenris is included is
because the Hulk needed something to
tussle with during the climactic final
battle
La Vie is a powerful force in Thor's
corner of the MCU but we never really
see much of him in action the king of
the frost Giants is the biological
father of Loki he has super strength and
ice powers but he's still no match for
the sneakiness of his own son Loki
manipulates events to get lopi to attack
asgarden Thor but just as loud he is
about to kill Odin Loki takes out laufi
instead killing the frost giant king and
making himself look like a hero in an
unceremonious ant Aldrich Killian turned
out to be the A-list bad guy in Iron Man
3. with Brampton Savin shaping up his
little more than b-list versions with
the same Powers both are given their
superheating and healing powers by the
extremist virus and they both attacked
Tony Stark throughout the film but
neither is a match for Iron Man even
when he doesn't have a suit it's easy to
forget but yes batroc the leaper is part
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe we meet
the French mercenary during the opening
chip hijacking sequence of the Winter
Soldier we get a breathless fight scene
between Captain America and batroc but
cap accepting batroc's challenge for a
hand-to-hand fight without his shield
thatrock holds his own though cap
eventually knocks him out ultimately
batroc is killed during the Falcon in
the Winter Soldier by Sharon Carter but
hey at least he's a little cooler than
this version
the real villain of Xiang Chi and the
legend of the ten Rings is not chongqi's
father Shu wenwoo but the being that
tricked him into Waging War on talo a
hidden magical realm this but ugly beast
the dweller in darkness leads the soul
leaders winged creatures that you
guessed it devour human Souls thousands
of years ago the great protector trapped
the dweller in darkness inside a
mountain but it never stopped trying to
escape when it finally does break free
Shang Chi must use the ten rings and
defeat the Beast before it wreaks havoc
on talo once again chongqi riding the
Falcor light great protector as he
fights the dweller is cool but as a
villain the big bad Soul Eater is dull
it is one of Marvel's scarier CGI
designs but the character is forgettable
a blur of tendrils and teeth and the
dark final showdown
Spider-Man homecoming gave us not just
one but two Shockers we meet the first
shocker Jackson Bryce as he's wielding a
shocker Gauntlet but after the vulture
kills him the weapons pass to Hermann
Schultz Schultz looks to be our main
shocker in the MCU and he gets one epic
fight against Spidey before being
sidelined shocker jumps Peter as he
leaves the school dance attempting to
follow the vulture the villain sends
Spidey flying through a school bus
knocking his web shooters off in the
process so why does shocker rank so low
because it wasn't even Spidey who took
him out it was Pete's pal Ned who grabs
a web shooter and hits shocker
distracting him long enough for Spidey
to web him to a school bus Baron von
strucker led the experiments on Loki's
scepter that created Quicksilver and the
Scarlet Witch so he's definitely
important but all anyone really
remembers about him is his immediate
surrender to the Avengers during the
opening of Age of Ultron
I'm
go surrender
the end strucker was just another Hydra
goon cut off his head and nobody really
noticed when the Destroyer shows up in
Thor it makes full use of every moment
the destroyer's giant powerful arms and
legs can crush or stomp just about any
opponent and if they don't kill you it's
laser blast probably will we saw the
Destroyer kill a few Frost Giants then
lay waste to a small town in New Mexico
and Loki sent it to Earth hunting Thor
still it was no match for Thor when the
God of Thunder regained his power and
overcharged the Destroyer ending the
attack credit Sam Rockwell's unending
Charisma for Iron Man 2's Justin Hammer
not showing up at the very bottom of
this list as far as credible villains
are concerned Justin Hammer is an
absolute joke he runs an arms
manufacturer that's a rival to Stark
Industries except everything Hammer
builds falls apart the first version of
the war machine armor is basically a
Bare Bones Iron Man suit outfitted with
a ton of hammer weapons which works just
about as well as duct taping accessories
to a car to summarize Sam Rockwell is
great Justin Hammer still kind of sucks
though Dr Samuel Stearns doesn't
actually ever call himself the leader
which is his villainous identity in the
comics but the Incredible Hulk isn't
exactly subtle about The Eccentric
scientist's Destiny the last we see of
him he's on the ground is the hulkified
blood he just pumped into Emil Blonsky
drips into an open wound on his head if
a Hulk sequel had come to pass we would
almost certainly have seen Tim Blake
Nelson return as the psychic and super
intelligent leader Nelson is perfect as
an obsessed scientist who doesn't care
much about the consequences of pursuing
his goals across ethical lines while he
never actually turns green on screen he
shows plenty of signs of a moral compass
in need of some fine tuning he clones a
whole room full of banners blood without
Bruce's knowledge or consent and he has
no problem with the notion of turning
Blonsky into Abomination and of course
in his final moments in the movie he's
seen smiling when any sane person would
be horrified
Spider-Man no way home masterfully
Blends three generations of Spider-Man
movies not only did Toby Maguire and
Andrew Garfield return as their
respective versions of Peter Parker but
the villains they fought in their film
showed up in the MCU too
well some of the old Spidey villains get
Grand entrances lizard and amputee
doctor who goes all villain after
injecting himself with an experimental
serum designed to regenerate limbs does
not he's captured by Doctor Strange
off-screen while Peter is dealing with
more memorable Spider-Man foes from
Years Gone by real name Kirk Connors
lizard originally did battle with Andrew
Garfield's Peter Parker when he appears
briefly in human form it's widely
believed to be in repurposed shots taken
from 2012's The Amazing Spider-Man in
the new movie Marvel opted to keep
lizard largely CGI and he's really only
there to make up the numbers he wasn't
exactly hit the first time around and
lizard did little to increase his
standing with fans here
in The Incredible Hulk General Thaddeus
Thunderbolt raw spends the entire film
trying and failing to kill Bruce Banner
and for much of the film he's a
relatively one-dimensional military bad
guy interestingly however Ross is one of
the few characters from The Incredible
Hulk to resurface later in the MCU he
became the U.S Secretary of State and
Captain America Civil War pushing for
the adoption of the sokovia Accords and
even made cameos an Infinity war and end
game General Ross will be taking on a
lead role in 2024's Thunderbolts movie
where he'll be betrayed by Harrison Ford
the character's original actor William
Hurt passed away in 2022
in one of Marvel's most bizarre casting
decisions to date British actor Ray
Winston took on the role of General
drakoff in 2021's Black Widow Drake off
personally sent Natasha and her sister
of sorts Elena bolova to the infamous
red room and he continued to oversee the
program after Natasha returned to
America and joined the Avengers he
doesn't have any superpowers but with an
army of highly trained killers at his
disposal he's a powerful man Winston has
some presents but his Perma scowl and
hodgepodge accent ultimately let him
down leading to a villain who was a
little lesson memorable when you look
into the eyes of a child you have raised
no mosque in the world can hide then in
an effort to capture the whole
humiliated Soldier Emil Blonsky hits
himself with an experimental version of
the same gamma stuff that makes hulks
into hulks except it doesn't turn him
into another Hulk instead he becomes the
Abomination a monstrous one note
creature that looks like a rotting troll
yawn he lives through the end of The
Incredible Hulk and is apparently in a
jail cell somewhere a storyline which
the MC returns to on the Disney plus
series She-Hulk Attorney at Law in the
series we see a much more Zen Blonsky
who has seemingly put his villainous
ways behind him ultimately in the finale
of the series The Abomination comes out
and balonski ends up in a jail cell
right back where he started dark elf
malekith had almost no personality and
basically existed as a freaky looking
dude trying to get an infinity stone and
Thanos already does that way way better
it's a shame because on the surface
malekith is extremely formidable even
stages of surprise assault on Asgard
itself reaching the city's defenses and
later sets his sights on Earth he puts
up a heck of a fight against Thor in the
Final Act of the Dark World though the
God of Thunder still prevails
when America Chavez and Doctor Strange
arrive on Earth 838 they learned that
mordo is this world sorcerer Supreme at
first he seems glad to see strange he's
jovial he's chatty he serves them tea
but you should never drink tea from
multiversal magicians soon enough a
drugged strange finds himself on trial
in front of the Illuminati and while the
other members of this Elite group might
be willing to give the doc a chance
mordo is dead set on strange ending up
dead while a38 morto is power hungry 616
mordo seems like a much more principled
villain sure he may have it out for
Sorcerers but at least he's operating
from a set of actual beliefs even if
they are twisted as Rocket points out
more than a few times taserface has a
pretty dumb name but he still has enough
cunning to lead a mutiny among yondu's
crew of ravagers his big mean rootless
and conniving and broker is an uneasy
alliance with nebula to take yondu's
ship he isn't all that bright but hey
those other four traits go a long way
for a while anyway of course the space
pirate suffers quite the defeat going up
in a ball of flame while someone laughs
at his stupid name
Crow is the leader of the deviance a
race of near Immortals made by the
all-powerful celestials he's had plenty
of memorable moments in the comics but
Crow was reduced to a diamond dozen CGI
Beastie in the eternals movie he looks
like a giant alien dog when he first
emerges and even though he begins to
take on a humanoid form as he absorbs
power from the eternals it's hard to
take Crow seriously as a villain when he
meets his end at the hands of Angelina
Jolie's Dina it's not a moment too soon
Mickey rourke's Whiplash was one of many
problems in Iron Man 2 despite some
admittedly awesome action scenes along
the way Whiplash never feels all that
intimidating at least after that epic
attack at the Monaco Grand Prix he's
motivated by a vague kind of boring
backstory and teams up with Justin
Hammer who we've already established
kind of sucks and then there was that
odd obsession with his bird
Adam Warlock is one of the most powerful
villains in the mcu's whole history he
has super strength flight
indestructibility and almost every other
superpower needed to kill off Marvel's
Plucky Intergalactic Heroes the
Guardians of the Galaxy fans first see
warlock when he interrupts the Guardians
in an attempt to kidnap rocket at the
behest of the high evolutionary warlock
can easily defeat any member of the
Guardians in a one-on-one battle but
when they work together it's a different
story warlock is clearly a powerful
villain but he lacks Drive warlock's
entire motivation appears to be pleasing
his mother who is attempting to court
paper with a high evolutionary to
persuade and not to destroy their home
planet his lack of purpose essentially
reduces him to a thug ultimately warlock
realizes that he wasn't cut out to be a
villain and from the audience
perspective it's hard to disagree
Thomas Hayden Church made his debut as
Marvel's Flint Marco in 2007 Spider-Man
3. but popped up again in Spider-Man no
way home the trouble is Marco's story
was pretty well wrapped up in Sam
raimi's third Spider-Man flick making
him something of a spare part when he
pops up in the MCU he helps Peter when
he first shows up but of course set
doesn't last Marco gets talked into
turning on the hero ultimately Sandman
feels like a token presence in a film
packed with multiple heroes and villains
sandman's only real purpose in the film
is that cool slow motion shot they used
in the trailers tanelier Tavon better
known as a collector has a remarkably
low-key career as an MCU villain you
might understandably question whether
he's really a Villain at all look
carefully and you can see that he's
pretty darn evil as early as his first
appearance in a Thor the Dark World
mid-credits scene we learned that one of
his goals is to collect all of the
Infinity Stones but probably just for
bragging rights not Conquering the
universe but a closer look at his
expansive collection reveals a whole lot
of unwilling prisoners we're fairly
certain that if the collector were ever
given a more active role in the MCU he'd
earn a higher spot on this list there's
something intriguing about the way he's
been on the periphery of the narrative's
most cataclysmic events mystery
surrounds Devon including the mystery of
whether or not he's still alive
decides to take out Tony Stark while
Starks on an overseas tour in the first
Iron Man film he contacts the terrorist
organization the 10 Rings led by Raza to
make it happen Raza keeps start captive
and proves an intimidating Villain at
least until stork builds his first
version of the Iron Man suit and makes
short work of rasa's soldiers Raza was
Savvy enough to survive and he Tracked
Down stray bits of Stark's armor and
tried to cut another deal with stain
problem stain was more savvy than Raza
and used a Sonic taser to paralyze him
and kill his man despite his own
ceremonies ending Raza is still
technically the first villain we meet in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and a
throwback to the simple days of the MCU
korath has a small but memorable role in
Guardians of the Galaxy which provided
one of the most memorable moments from
the movie's opening scenes hey you know
what there's another name you might know
me by
Star-Lord
who Star-Lord man the Star-Lord gets the
better of him poor ass still puts up a
heck of a fight he also manages to
reacquire the infinity stone along with
nebula which sets up Ronan the accuser's
near world ending attack on xandar
without Korra thronin would never have
had the infinity stone to begin with so
he certainly served a purpose even holds
his own against Drax the Destroyer for a
while at least until Drax rips out the
cybernetic implant in his head killing
him hey at least he went out fighting
Andy Circus actually does an extremely
entertaining job with Ulysses claw in
both Age of Ultron as well as black
panther which gives us a believable
version of The Claw we knew from the
comics and cartoons a character who
still has the potential to come back
after his death is a dude made of sound
waves hopefully the MCU will resurrect
this classic comics b-lister for future
super villainous action Walton Goggins
is a genuine Delight every time he shows
up on screen and his appearance in
Ant-Man and the WASP is no exception
sure Sonny Birch doesn't do much
compared to the likes of killmonger or
Thanos but he might be one of the mcu's
most comic book ever as a dealer in
illicit technology Birch is a character
that like the vulture operates on the
fringes of a universe filled with magic
Hammers and alien technology the
difference is birch is the kind of
sleazy Mastermind who rolls around in a
white and gold SUV conducts his illegal
business in broad daylight and commands
an army of nameless motorcycle riding
henchmen Birch is the perfect character
to have around to reinforce the idea
that there's more to this world than
Shakespearean gods and Magic space rocks
arsham the judge operates in the gray
area of villainy but to the people of
Earth the prime Celestial is absolutely
a bad guy this ancient Bean is said to
have created the first Sun bringing
lights warmth then therefore life into
the universe creating new life is
arashim's thing but the big bad of
eternals doesn't mind losing a few lives
in the process the end of One Life
Cersei
is the beginning of another
in eternals we discover that a Celestial
seed was planted in Earth's core long
ago it said Celestial breaks through
Earth's crust it will kill the planet
and everything on it of course arashim
expects the eternals to fulfill their
true purpose and Usher in Earth's Doom
but they've grown quite fond of the
planet and its inhabitants over the
Millennium most side with the humans and
conspire to thwart the birth of Tiamat
while arashim looks pretty cool the
prime celestial's main purpose in
eternals is exposition the creator of
galaxies takes a deep dive into the
history of the universe which may be
enjoyable for the sake of the lore but
is a bit of a drag when it comes to the
movies pacing and it doesn't make much
of an impression as a bad guy beyond
that
she might not have been the big bad and
guarding into the Galaxy Vol 2 but the
Golden Goddess Aisha was able to cause
more than enough trouble for Star-Lord
and his team the leader of the powerful
Sovereign she commands a fleet of remote
controlled warships that come within one
shot of taking out the Milana following
an extensive Chase moreover the
post-credits scene revealed Aisha is
partly responsible for creating Adam
Warlock a major player in Marvel's
Cosmic universe and Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 she leads the Sovereign in
trying to capture rocket to save their
own planet from the high evolutionary's
wrath ultimately she is seemingly killed
on counter Earth when the high
evolutionary destroys the planet
the chatari basically served as cannon
fodder against Earth's Mightiest Heroes
in the final hour of the Avengers even
still they are a massive alien Army led
by those positively terrifying gigantic
Dragon ships at tortu Manhattan their
eventual humiliation notwithstanding the
chitari were more than formidable enough
to push the Avengers to the brink in
their first big screen team up and when
they returned for their big final battle
and end game their only strength seems
to be in numbers and they were defeated
just as easily in Captain America the
First Avenger arnim Zola's appearance is
basically just an Easter egg in Winter
Soldier however the setup of having Zola
around for the first movie pays off in a
cool way you might not be a robot with a
camera for a head and his face on a
giant TV screen built into his guts like
in the comics but when winter soldiers
big reveal lacks in robot bodies it more
than makes up for by making him
genuinely creepy
Ant-Man and the WASP super powered
villain ghost has a lot going for
visually her flickering and phasing
through objects is some of the coolest
looking stuff we've seen in the MCU it's
even better in the fight scenes the
shrinking and growing stuff is fun but
pitting that stuff against a completely
different set of powers makes for some
pretty compelling action since she
seemingly reforms at the end of the film
were obviously meant to like her she has
a sympathetic backstory as a victim of
Hank Pimp's egotistical past but at the
same time we're also supposed to like
Hank so his Parts in ghost backstory
still involves him ultimately being
right none of this is too surprising
Marvel is full of bad guys doing the
wrong thing for the right reasons but it
does feel pretty clear that ghost was
shoehorned into Ant-Man and the WASP
rather than building her more
organically still the effects are great
and Hannah John Common's performance
captures Ava's understandable bitterness
and Desperation effectively ghost will
be making her return to the MCU in
2024's Thunderbolts
scorpion is a pretty big deal in the
comics but in Spider-Man homecoming not
so much his most notable actions are
complete failures first when an arms
deal is interrupted by Spider-Man and
then later when he tries to get the
Sinister Six going in prison before
being shut down by the vulture basically
he's just there to make Adrian tombs
look cooler by comparison and when
you're not as cool as the vulture it's
safe to say you screwed up pretty bad
somewhere along the way
anyone familiar with Marvel Comics knew
some kind of villainous turn was coming
for mordo and Doctor Strange while he
spends most of the film with Strange's
Ally the angry sorcerer abandons his
allies after strange makes his bargain
with dormammu after the credits we see
mordo become the Nemesis he's long been
in the comics declaring there are too
many Sorcerers in the world 616 mordo
doesn't make an appearance in Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness but
he's bound to pop up again in a possible
future Doctor Strange sequel plus he's
played by chewatel egio4 the
oscar-nominated actor is not only a
superb performer but he's particularly
great in villainous roles as far as
secondary muscle villains go nomura and
atuma are pretty solid bad guys we dig
their look blueskinned Mesoamerican
Warriors wearing water masks to help
them breathe on the surface world and
perhaps for the first time in MCU
history the Dora milaje find themselves
equaled and occasionally outmatched by
these two foes while these lower level
villains are definitely outshone by
their King we have to give him props for
being so Fierce and terrifying when
they're looking to crack some skulls the
Blackboard or perfectly serviceable
henchman for Infinity War they managed
to hit that sweet spot of being
threatening enough to present the heroes
with a challenge but they also provide
additional room for the action so that
it's not just 40 people trying to punch
Thanos at the same time ultimately
they're not so threatening that they
overshadow the actual villain of the
piece each of them is distinct and
Visually menacing especially ebony Maul
unfortunately most of them don't
actually get to do much other than lose
so that's a bit of a drawback
and Guardians of the Galaxy Ronin was a
religious zealot who co-opted the Power
Stone to continue his crusade to wipe
out xandar but even without one of those
awesomely powerful baubles he's still a
heck of a warrior after all he laid ways
to Drax the Destroyer without even
breaking his sweat he also had the guts
to stick it to Thanos and actually
walked away from the Mad Titan without
much Consequence the Guardians were no
match for Ronan individually but luckily
Star-Lord was able to actually control
the infinity stone with the help of his
team this has Celestial powers and some
sweet dance moves all of those things
together and Star-Lord was able to blast
the bad guy into Oblivion ant-man's
Darren cross spent his entire career
trying to duplicate Hank pym's shrinking
formula but when he did it and created
the yellowjacket combat suit he didn't
realize his copycat formula was actually
messing with his brain making him
dangerously unstable that led to a
villain who was not only dangerously
unhinged but got some really cool fight
scenes the best of which was on a
child's play table
the high evolutionary considers himself
a deity attempting to write the wrongs
of modern society he attempts to achieve
this by constructing new worlds and
civilizations such as counter Earth I'm
not trying to conquer the universe I'm
perfecting it but when he discovers a
flaw in one of his Creations he decides
to destroy it and start over even though
his Creations are sentient and have
lives beyond the limits of his
imagination in Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 the high evolutionary is revealed
to be the one who first created rocket
by painfully modifying the mind of a
raccoon the high evolutionary was
experimenting on animals to build a new
world in which other species not humans
are at the top of the food chain but
when the high evolutionary learns that
this new civilization is sliding into
the same harmful habits that humans have
such as violent drug trafficking he
decides to wipe out the entire new
Society Die Hard comic fans know surter
is a major villain in Thor's World in
Thor Ragnarok however he appears only in
the opening act and destructive finale
that's not to say he's not important to
the story in Norse mythology the word
Ragnarok points to the Apocalypse battle
between Gods it results in a world
destroyed by fire while Searcher is
indeed the monster all-ass Guardians
fear Thor and Loki summon him to invoke
the Ragnarok prophecy this defeats hella
but at a price his attack decimates
Asgard crumbling the city in the sky to
dust
when Marvel asked Annette Bening to play
a villain in Captain Marvel they
probably didn't open with you're going
to be a giant green disembodied head
with a bunch of gross tendrils floating
in some kind of Goo that would be an
accurate description of the character's
physical appearance in the comics but
instead of the bulbous floating head
captain Marvel's creative directors
chose to represent the AI that rules the
cree Empire as a kind of psychic
projection everyone who communes with
the Supreme intelligence sees someone
different and in Carol's case the
intelligence appears as her Mentor
Marvel as viewers we spend a lot of time
in Captain Marvel thinking these scrolls
are the bad guys once the truth is
revealed it's Yang Rog who's the most
visible villain perhaps in the future
we'll see more of the cree ruler giving
the Supreme intelligence a chance to get
a better spot on this list
Red Skull easily stands out as one of
the most original and terrifying baddies
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe in the
First Avenger He commands his own Hydra
branded Nazi division complete with
Tesseract powered weapons and has his
own version of the super soldier serum
making him caps physical equal he
vanished while trying to harness the
power of the Tesseract space Stone but
his surprise return is a guardian of the
Soul Stone in Infinity War only serve to
remind us how great he was so many years
ago
he might have just been a disciple of
dormammu but kaisilius was plenty
intimidating in his own right highly
trained sorcerer who went rogue let the
ancient ones order to try and take out
the masters of the Mystic Arts and
nearly succeeded and Dr Strange casilius
manages to destroy two sanctums but the
ancient one's forces on the ropes and
shows his prowess with magic and a few
excellent fight sequences luckily a
quick thinking strange manages to turn
the tables and win the day
the tinkerer is exactly the kind of
character that the MCU needed for the
same reason that he was exactly the kind
of character that the comics needed
someone who builds all the gadgets the
bad guys use to fight the good guys he's
certainly not the focus of Spider-Man
homecoming but Phineas Mason is a kind
of quiet bad guy who makes the MCU feel
just a bit more real
every great ruler needs someone beside
them to carry their melting stick in
Thor Ragnarok that job goes to Topaz the
sadistic and unforgiving right-hand
woman to the Grand Master and she's a
perfect match for her eccentric boss
while he Delights in his games and
Acquisitions topaz stands ready nearby
with his instrument of torture always
eager for The Grandmaster to melt people
unfortunately for the Grand Master topaz
does not survive Ragnarok and crashes
while chasing Bruce Banner Thor and
Valkyrie during their escape from sakhar
topaz is service to Grand Master is
clearly not forgotten in one of Marvel's
shorts we see that The Grandmaster has
built a Mana Shrine to his former
assistant in his new Los Angeles
apartment
of all the impressive things about
Spider-Man homecoming one of the most
notable is just how many characters the
film pulled in from the comics and the
best minor villain appearance by far is
absolutely Aaron Davis known in the
comics as the prowler in the film he's
hilariously and thoroughly unimpressed
by Peter Parker's enhanced interrogation
well I don't know your voice
I heard you got a bridge I know what A
girl sound like I'm not a boy I'm a boy
it's one of the best comedic scenes in
the entire MCU but what really makes it
special is Davis's mention of his nephew
as Comics readers know Davis's nephew is
Miles Morales who eventually takes the
name of Spider-Man as far as villainy
goes Davis doesn't accomplish much
Beyond a failed arms deal hinting at a
future the MCU that includes miles
though that's awesome throughout doctor
strange and the Multiverse of Madness
Scarlet Witch sends out quite a few
demons to do her bidding but the monster
who makes the biggest impact is without
a doubt gargantos based on the comic
book villain Schumacher wrath gargantos
is a tentacle beast that's out to kidnap
America Chavez and drag her back to one
the maximoff unlike some generic MCU
monsters gargantos is instantly
memorable with its slimy Limbs and giant
eye and gargantos is quite the imposing
bow as it takes a combined forces of Dr
Strange Wong and America to ultimately
bring the creature down
sure the ravagers aren't all villains at
the end of Guardians of the Galaxy
plenty of them sacrifice themselves to
save xandar but in the sequel we see a
darker side of these mercenaries when
taserface takes over yondu's ravagers
everyone's still loyal to yondu is
rewarded by being ejected into space as
their former comrades laugh and wait
most of them are also more than happy to
abuse poor baby Groot and of all their
survivors only craglin refrains from
trying to kill yondu rocket and Broods
as they escape as villains the ravagers
don't accomplish a lot and without
someone like yondu or nebula supporting
them they don't provide much of a
challenge to the heroes but while they
may be cannon fodder they still give us
all a lot of laughs their well-deserved
beatings provide some of the most fun
sequences and Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol 2. Brock rumlo started out as a
member of Captain America's Strike Team
and Winter Soldier eventually revealing
himself as a Hydra agent when the
attempted takeover began he managed to
survive and resurface during the opening
fights in Civil War where he went
toe-to-toe with both cap and black widow
before blowing himself up in the event
that ended up driving The Avengers part
for villain that's a pretty good way to
go out
dormammu is one of the biggest villains
in Marvel Comics and surprisingly the
MCU actually kept the extremely powerful
ruler of the dark dimension relatively
close to his Comics counterpart Dr
Strange's trip to the dark dimension was
practically a Steve ditko panel brought
to life dormammu is so powerful that
doctor strange had no chance of hurting
him so he had to outsmart him to save
the world trapping the villain in a Time
Loop where dormammu killed him over and
over until he was forced to bargain for
his freedom it makes for one of the most
clever finales in all of the MCU and
lands dormammu high on our list of
favorites
death dealer is a skilled Warrior loyal
to Shang Chi's father when his boss
ordered him to train his son he became
the most brutal teacher you could
imagine
enough to sun down I was taught every
possible way to kill a man his history
with the hero and his eye-catching
costume made death dealer one of
Marvel's more interesting villains of
recent memory but the character wouldn't
have worked so well if it wasn't for the
high-flying performance of a relative
unknown named Andy lay in fact death
dealers knife fight with Sean Chi is one
of the standout sequences in a film
packed with impressive action the
Revelation that young Rog is actually
the bad guy in Captain Marvel is the
kind of twist that barely even needs a
spoiler warning it's an almost foregone
conclusion from the moment that we find
out that the cree Allied Warrior veers
is actually test pilot Carol Danvers
through flashbacks that poke holes in
his version of Carol's origin what
really makes it work is the same thing
that we see in a lot of great MCU
villains going all the way back to
Obadiah stain consistency of character
yon Rog never changes there's no
dramatic heel turn or big reveal he
really does want Carol Danvers to be the
best version of herself that she can be
you even get the sense at the end of the
film that for all their Photon blasting
combat he still likes her as a person
this all comes to a head in their final
confrontation in which young Rog takes
credit for Carol's Newfound Unstoppable
power that's the moment he goes from
Insidious to insufferable and sets up
what might be the most purely enjoyable
defeat of a villain in MCU history
Black Widow Finally Revealed what
happened in Budapest a place that had
been name dropped in the MCU on several
occasions but remained shrouded in
mystery Natasha Romanov and her good
friend Clint Barton tried to assassinate
drakoff in the Hungarian Capital
planting a bomb in his office he managed
to come through the blast relatively
unscathed but his young daughter wasn't
so lucky Antonio drakov sustained severe
injuries in the explosion and her dear
old dad decided to use her as a guinea
pig inserting a chip into her neck that
stopped her suffering but turned her
into the perfect Soldier she was able to
perfectly mimic the fighting style of
anyone she came across including Black
Widow as a result Antonia became the
villain Taskmaster though she's really
just another victim of Draco Taskmaster
will re-enter the MCU in the upcoming
Thunderbolts movie
multiversal Adventure Stephen Strange
learns about the existence of multiple
other doctors all of whom walk a fine
line between hero and villain but
there's one master of the Mystic Arts
who's taken the plunge all the way into
the deep dark side of the pool that's
the so-called Sinister strange who
presides over an annihilated Universe
corrupted by the dark hole this version
of strange Sports a third eye Grieves
over the loss of Christine in his
universe and spends his spare time
murdering various other Stranges
needless to say this Sinister sorcerer
and our beloved hero do not get along
especially when the villain sets his
sights on Earth 838's Christine here's
the deal I'll let you use the dark hole
if you give me your Christine as a
result we're treated to an epic duel of
magical musical notes which is one of
the reasons we're ranking this Baddie so
high as the two magicians battle with
treble clefs we're reminded that when
you've got an invented villain you can
have a whole lot of fun
after one final explosive tussle with
Gamora nebula joins Society of the
angels and guarding into the Galaxy Vol
2. that's not true of every version of
nebula we meet in fact it's indirectly
because of nebula that Thanos gets to
wage his final battle against the good
guys in endgame when nebula goes back in
time to 2014 to help get the orb the
nebula of that time becomes aware of her
the 2014 nebula isn't reformed she's
still loyally killing anything and
everything her father tells her to as
well as harboring murderous jealousy
towards Gamora 2014 nebula is pretty
tragic even when she's confronted by her
heroic future self the 2014 nebula sees
no way out she clearly wants to be
different but she ultimately dies
because of her refusal to change even
though the proof that she can change is
literally standing in front of her when
Marvel signed Robert Redford for a
superhero movie you knew it'd be an
interesting role and his turn is
Alexander Pierce delivered he's
introduced as the well-meaning secretary
of the world Security Council and old
friend of Nick Fury though it's
eventually revealed Pierce is actually a
Hydra agent leading their infiltration
of Shield Pierce Shepard did the program
designed to create the network
telecarrier system everyone is fighting
over in the Winter Soldier he also
planted bombs in the name tags of the
other Security Council Members which he
uses to brutally murder them when they
challenge his takeover he stayed evil to
the end too uttering hail Hydra with his
dying breath after Nick Fury put two
rounds into his chest now that's a
villain
Jamie Foxx was one of the first former
Spider-Man villains to confirm that he
was reprising his role in the MCU even
revealing that he would have an all-new
look for Spider-Man no way home it was
the first of many leaks that Marvel
attempted to plug as production grew
nearer as a result nobody was surprised
to see Jamie Foxx's Max Dillon cross
over into the mcu's Spidey Universe
chance at Redemption for the actor Fox
debuted as Electro in 2014's The Amazing
Spider-Man 2 the film that brought
Andrew Garfield's 10 euros Marvel's web
Slinger to an early end a third film was
planned but the lukewarm response to the
second installment meant another reboot
was around the corner the general
consensus among fans was that fox got
hung out to dry with bad writing goofy
wardrobe choices and distracting CGI the
version of Electro he played in
Spider-Man no way home went down much
better with viewers by being far cooler
more menacing and more Electric
when Thor is suddenly marooned on the
junk planet's a car he comes in contact
with a grand master in the comics the
Grand Master is just an immortal dude
who loves playing games of any kind but
in the hands of Jeff Goldblum The
Grandmaster becomes one of the weirdest
and funniest characters in the MCU
here's hoping we get to see a lot more
of him in the future though maybe not as
much as he wants us to on any other
world I'd be like millions of years old
here on sakar
brazzer fist is as Katie Chen puts it
I got real name Matthias he's the
adopted son of shangshi's Father Shu Wen
Wu razor fist was sent by Wen Wu to
retrieve Xiang Chi leading to what's
undoubtedly the film's best scene the
boss fight the movie's Hero has yet to
reveal to longtime friend Katie that
he's highly trained in martial arts so
she's just as surprised to see him
kicking butts as she is by the Man
attacking him the sequence combines
comedy with inspired Close Quarters
fight choreography executed perfectly by
simu Liu of course it takes two to tango
and the bus fight wouldn't have been so
badass if it wasn't for Florian montiano
a former boxer he was best known for
playing Victor Drago in Creed II before
joining the MCU as razor fist
you have to respect where it all began
and Jeff Bridge's Obadiah stain AKA Iron
Monger set the tone for the villains of
the MCU in the first Iron Man film
Bridge's stain is positively slimy
betraying Tony Stark and inadvertently
setting his entire Heroes journey in
action so really we can thank stain for
kicking off the entire MCU when his
assassination attempt on Stark in the
desert fails stain eventually dons the
massive Iron Monger suit to try and
finish the job himself a lot has changed
since Iron Monger stalked the skies but
his final fight with Iron Man had a
brutal messy feel that really lets you
feel the hate staying had for Stark and
it still resonates even in a world with
Heavy Hitters like Thanos prowling
around
the MCU once had a reputation for being
a franchise with great Heroes and subpar
villains and a big part of that was The
Benchmark set by the likes of Alfred
Molina the Brit raised the bar for
on-screen super villainy with his turn
as Auto Octavius AKA Doctor Octopus or
simply Doc Ock in 2004's Spider-Man 2. a
brilliant scientist and inventor
Octavius became a villain when the AI
mechanical limbs he created fused with
his nervous system during an accident in
the lab when dakak arrives in Spider-Man
no way home he's the first of the
Multiverse hopping villains to show up
on screen and he still has a bone to
pick with Spider-Man but using Stark
Industries Tech the MCU Peter Parker
frees octavius's mind from his AI
appendages and brings him back to his
old self he's unwilling and able to help
track down the other new arrivals
becoming a major part of the plot
James Spader's chilling voice brought
absolute Terror to the metal Menace that
was Ultron with a near endless supply of
robot bodies and a design that had
Comics fans geeking out he exemplifies
how technology can be our greatest
Scourge though Ultron does it with a wit
that only Spader can provide verbally
sparring with the best of them like any
great villain Ultron also has a real
motivation for his dastardly Deeds
looking at the facts ultron's final
determination that humans and
superheroes are what make the world such
a dangerous place makes its own Twisted
kind of sense
eternals would have benefited from
spending less time with its big CGI
baddies and more time with Richard
Madden's Icarus who betrayed his fellow
eternals when they opposed arishim's
plan Icarus learned of Earth's intended
fate centuries before his comrades did
let in on the terrible Secret by ajak
the prime Eternal when the time came and
Ajax began to have second thoughts about
the emergence Icarus killed her he was
determined to fulfill his purpose
believing the obliteration of Earth to
be in the greater interest of the
universe it's a question that Icarus
debates to a certain point but even his
love for fellow Eternal Cersei can't
completely sway him in the end leading
to a complicated ending for the hero
turned antagonist in a press conference
for the movie Madden said he's kind of
trying to bury that love because it gets
in the way of his duty he's constantly
wrestling with the two and that's kind
of what made it really interesting to me
Iron Man 3 is one of the most polarizing
movies in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
featuring an epic bakeout that reveals
guy Pierce's Aldrich Killian is actually
the villain behind a mysterious rash of
bombings and terrorist attacks sweeping
the globe secret weapon extremis a
versatile technology that first showed
up in the Iron Man comics and is
reimagined here as a way to superheat
one's body and literally regrow limbs
Killian's particular skill set makes for
one of the most technically ambitious
fight scenes in the MCU it's sometimes
hard to believe any villain can truly go
toe-to-toe with Tony Stark but Killian
made a heck of a run generally speaking
the very best Marvel villains are the
ones with sympathetic backstories and
they don't get much more sympathetic
than the tragic tale of Gore the god
butcher a disciple of the god rapu Gore
loses his faith after the death of his
daughter especially once he discovers
that rapu doesn't care about his loss
armed with the cursed necro sword Gore
swears Revenge vowing to kill every God
in existence is that the necro sword
that's cool I've only ever read about it
in stories and you know this is going to
uh played with a wonderfully
over-the-top theatricality by Christian
Bale Gore hops back and forth from a
leering sadistic swordsman to a man
absolutely racked with pain at one
moment he takes great joy attacking town
and taunting a cage full of children and
the next he's lost in thoughts
remembering the precious little girl he
lost as we see in the film's climactic
moments Gore is a man who's haunted by
the past and who craves one thing more
than Vengeance love
the most amazing thing about helmet Zemo
in Civil War is that he's just an
average guy with no real plans for world
domination he's just a man who wants
revenge for the death of his family and
he's wise enough to realize the best way
to take out the Avengers is to set them
against one another yes his plan does
require a few big leaps of movie logic
but it was refreshing to see a Villain
Like Zemo brought to life in the MCU
he's a great reminder that it doesn't
take World smashing superpowers to give
Earth's Mightiest Heroes a run for their
money his scene stealing appearance in
the Disney plus series The Falcon and
the Winter Soldier helping titular
Heroes stop the flag Smashers is a
definite highlight for the show the
entire MCU should be unnoticed with Zemo
out in the world plotting this next move
Peter Quill's search for his father was
a key part of Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol 2 a journey that brought him face to
face with Kurt Russell's ego who's as
bad a dad as they come ego is one of the
most powerful villains in the MCU right
up there alongside Thanos himself Eagles
essentially a God who wants to literally
become the universe by replacing all
other life and Russell sells it so well
that you really understand where ego's
coming from even if he's a psychopath
who's killed hundreds of his own
children in his quest for power ego
redefined the concept of daddy issues of
course I have issues that's my freaking
father
Mysterio isn't the best villain in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but he might
just be the cleverest after 10 years of
movies inspired by Comics the MCU proved
with endgame that it was its own
distinct version of the superhero
Universe a series of alternate surprises
led to Mysterio with a promise of a
Multiverse that could take thanks to the
next level and then we find out that
it's all just one big con instead of
being the way forward Mysterio ties
everything back to the very first Iron
Man movie and is one of the many things
that make far from home the perfect
epilogue to the infinity Saga monoch is
a Giant floating head with tiny baby
limbs who also happens to be really good
at murdering superheroes an Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania he gets a little
extra character twist modok is what's
left of Darren cross every time he flies
onto the screen in his doomsday chair
the movie gets 10 times better he shoots
lasers he's got giant Buzz saws and he
just loves killing in the service of
King the Conqueror of course Modoc also
gets a quick hero turn near the end of
the film and gives himself an
interesting title as he lays dying and
at least I died
Avengers
[Music]
yeah no it's you're in it's one of the
film's best jokes from its most
unbelievably awesome character and
that's why modak gets his own entry
independent from Darren
we've never seen Thor face a Villain
Like hella the goddess of death in any
of the other MCU films much like Loki
before her this Asgardian villain as
someone audiences will immediately love
to hate as soon as Odin passes away
hella appears to the brothers and
presents her plan to take her rightful
place on asgard's Throne to prove her
Point she easily crushes Thor's hammer
the truth is eventually revealed that
hella once acted as Odin's executioner
leading the Asgardian Army to victory
over all nine Realms the secret history
elevates hella to Epic villain status
it's hard to fully judge king the
Conqueror because we know he's coming
back in some way or form and we'll
definitely see his variants in action
across the Multiverse Saga banished by
his variants to the quantum realm Kanga
spent his spare time building a new
Empire with his genius intellect and
super powered suit Kang is an
Unstoppable Force only prevented from
expanding his Empire thanks to Janet van
dyne's quick thinking and Scott Lang's
decision to sacrifice his future for the
greater good Kang seems to exist outside
of time as we know it he's seen the
future and all the horrors it brings and
he's killed The Avengers countless times
across the Multiverse when you can't
distinguish Ant-Man from Thor because
you butchered them both so easily and so
many times that's a sign of a bad dude
right there
is one of Marvel's best on-screen
villains to date he's a near mythical
figure who went by many names during his
unnaturally long life which was given to
him by the ten Rings he conquered lands
and spread his influence but when he
turned his attention to talo he fell in
love with the gatekeeper to the hidden
realm it's because we can sympathize
with wenwoo that he's such a memorable
villain Tony Liang Chui is fantastic in
the role not only in his action
sequences but in dramatic moments too
we'll need dweller in darkness breaks
free and when Wu realizes he's been
tricked the look he gives his son says a
thousand words when the creature sucks
out his soul moments later we're
actually sad to see him go it's an
intense yet dignified performance from
Liang Chui
in the midst of great tragedy Namor
created the underwater Kingdom of
talocon an Empire that Rivals the
surface world of wakanda Neymar deeply
cares about his people and his goal is
to keep them safe at all costs however
while the Aquatic King is filled with a
genuine lover of citizens it's matched
by his hatred for the Nations above
Namor is a big believer in preemptive
war and if he has to kill Riri Williams
flood wakanda or drown Queen Ramona to
protect his world he will ultimately
Neymar is the perfect foil for princess
shuri just as she's grieving the loss of
her family facing the encroachment of
other countries and figuring out how to
protect her people Namor is grappling
with the same issues it's how they
ultimately deal with those problems that
sets him apart as hero and villain
before he fought alongside Captain
America and the Falcon during Civil War
and Beyond Bucky Barnes was a zombified
super assassin under the control of
Hydra and he killed countless people
across multiple decades it's not
something Bucky likes talking about but
nevertheless his winter soldier Persona
is one of the scariest characters in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe with a
cybernetic arm of propensity for knife
fighting and sniper abilities at rival
Hawkeyes Bucky's Alter Ego is a force to
be reckoned with in Captain America the
Winter Soldier he nearly killed Nick
Fury he went toe-to-toe with Steve
Rogers in a Savage street fight and he
almost beat his best friend to death
only pulling his punches after Steve
jogged his memory and brought Bucky back
it's rare to see MCU Good Guys join the
Dark Side but that's exactly what
happens to Wanda maximoff and Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
after the events of One Division where
she lost her family but found the evil
corruptive darkhold Wanda has broken bad
she's hell-bent on murdering America
Chavez stealing her Multiverse hopping
powers and finding a world where she can
be with her boys Billy and Tommy granted
Wanda is a sympathetic villain she's
lost everyone and what parent wouldn't
do anything to see their kids again at
the same time the unwillingness to let
go of her grief is Wanda's ultimate
downfall turning her into the truly
terrifying Scarlet witch in a universe
of world destroying monsters the vulture
is decidedly street level in his
approach but that's exactly what makes
him work the film's writers tweaked his
backstory to make Adrian tombs the
father of Peter Parker's teenage Crush
in Spider-Man homecoming and he takes
the girlfriend's Angry Dad Trope to a
whole new level the effects team also
did an amazing job with his armor and
appearance with the vulture looking
positively terrifying and inhuman when
he's stalking his prey Eric killmonger
is essentially has a superhero's origin
his father is killed in front of him his
Royal Heritage is denied to him and he
uses those tragedies to motivate a
Relentless dedication training himself
to the peak of his abilities before
seeking Vengeance that setup is a whole
lot closer to Batman than it is to
Ultron when you add in the fact that
killmonger specifically wants to address
a continuing history of racism it's hard
not to admit that he makes some pretty
good points even if he's right though
his goal is dominance rather than
leadership which makes him a true
ideological opponent for t'challa it's
one of the things that makes their final
battle in which they're both in nearly
identical black panther costumes so good
they're reflections of each other both
committed to fight for their ideals
without compromising who they are
there's a reason Marvel Studios chose to
use Loki as an ongoing villain for The
Avengers he's one of the most compelling
calculated and charismatic villains ever
Tom Hiddleston is so good at being bad
that Marvel opted to keep him around
long after his bid for Supremacy was
spoiled at the hands of Earth's
Mightiest Heroes he's still no match for
the Hulk
[Applause]
who is oh wait we know who the dastardly
Loki we see in The Avengers makes
another appearance in the Disney plus
series Loki after escaping captivity
during the Time Heist and end game
despite his best attempts to stay
villainous this Loki also turns to the
Light Side just like his counterpart who
died at the hands of Thanos in Infinity
War Thanos is the villain of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe there's been a lot of
character work put into the Cinematic
version of Thanos which is especially
impressive considering that most of it
is shown to the audience in Infinity War
a movie that's also juggling story arcs
for dozens of other characters at the
same time through it all he's shown to
have the same quality that all the
greatest villains share he thinks he's
right he's the hero of his own story the
only one who can step up and save the
universe from itself and is willing to
sacrifice whatever he needs to in
pursuit of that goal in the comics
Thanos has been referred to as the
ultimate nihilist but the mcu's version
is the exact opposite he believes very
much in what he's doing which makes him
even more compelling and more dangerous
still there is one MCU villain who's
even more iconic than the Mad Titan
William Dafoe laid the groundwork for
the modern superhero movie villain with
his turn as the Oscorp founder Norman
Osborne in 2002 Spider-Man it was a
masterful performance from the four-time
Oscar nominee though many people think
that he topped it with his turn his
Green Goblin in no way home the foe
stole the show becoming the best MCU
movie villain to date in the process as
one Twitter user wrote even one laugh
out of him is more menacing than a
purple alien who wipes out half the
universe in a snap seriously I can't
stop raving about his performance almost
two decades later and he did Goblin
better
foreign